is now minister of Veterans Affairs
Johnny Mercer High okay how are you I'm
very well thanks for joining us I don't
think you've been on the sofa when I've
been in previously so it's nice to see
you thanks for coming in what are we
going to do about the Northern Ireland
protocol and the onpass that has been
created look I think uh it's clear that
Northern protocol doesn't work for any
size in Northern Ireland and prime
minister's doing everything he can to
resolve that and get to a solution that
preserves The Good Friday agreement and
make sure that there's the free flow of
trade in Northern Ireland I you know
that's been going off sometime I think
and uh you know we're looking forward to
resolving that and getting on and
realizing all the benefits of brexit are
you going to resolve it well look the
premises in negotiations at the moment
isn't he and uh you know he had good
discussions last week with the European
Union uh he's got good engagement going
on at the moment with with other MPS and
uh you know we'll see what comes out of
this yeah but because of brexit there
has to be a border somewhere Boris
Johnson's has said time and time again
ERG saying the same thing that there
cannot be a border in the the Irish sea
so that would mean there'd have to be a
border between Ireland and Northern
Ireland and that would be against the
Good Friday agreement so where does that
leave you it's okay obviously I mean it
feels like we're we're stuck in a Time
War doesn't it because we're talking
about same things that we've been
talking about four or five years let's
let's give the Prime Minister a chance
to come out with something right he's
attacking this uh he is throwing
everything he can see he voted for and
campaigned hard for brexit right so he's
not going to sell anyone out or come up
with a solution that's unfair or doesn't
deliver on what he thinks is brexit I
think let's give him a chance give him
the opportunity to uh to bring some sort
of resolution to the protocol and then
let's get behind him and get on with all
the other challenges that we Face across
this country at the moment a deal this
week
I don't know I hope so uh but let's see
what happens you know he's working hard
and let's see what happens talk to me
about uh you're brief you're not seeing
your money for projects helping yeah
veterans tell me more yeah so look uh
the health Innovation fund we're
launching today we um you know clearly
we're on a dry to make this the best
country in the world to be a veteran
there are some veterans who will wake up
this morning with really difficult
wounds that still don't heal and really
you know bed sores and pressure sores
and things like that and uh we're
investing in five million pounds in
technology companies and other companies
across the UK 22 different companies uh
looking at really Innovative and you
know exciting technologies that will
help people improve and heal their
wounds you know I was at a company
yesterday that looked at electronic
blasters right where you can you know
put these pluses on people who've had
amputations and so on and pass a current
through them and actually start to heal
some of these wounds that haven't healed
for such a long time so um look it's
really exciting I accept it it's niche
right but I think the way the country
looks after veterans is a big marker by
which we should be judged I think that's
fundamentally changed under this
government and um you know it's another
it's another Waypoint on on the way to
making this the best country in the
world
you have championed the troubles Legacy
bill you seem to be the only person that
does why are you continuing to plow on
with it well I don't think I am the only
person who does I think obviously the
Airways will be dominated by people who
don't like it which is supposed by all
parties in Northern Ireland the Irish
government and yeah yeah of course and
it's going to be right and if uh and if
it um if if they they were happy with it
I didn't I don't think we'd hear
anything about it the troubles the
trolls Legacy building online is
incredibly difficult right it's
incredibly sensitive you're dealing with
really really difficult issues that have
um reared their heads over the last 25
years since the Good Friday agreement I
think it's pretty clear that what has
happened and you've seen this over the
course of the last year
um is is not fair it's not fair on
anyone it's not delivering outcomes for
victims it's not delivering uh fairness
for veterans and uh um you know the
government was elected on Manifesto
promised to to bring that to a close and
bring you know bring some sort of uh
reconciliation and and resolution for
for victims in this space and you know
the government should be commended for
that it's not easy right solving what
has happened in Northern Ireland and
dealing with Legacy is not easy you
can't just throw slogans at it and say
you know we're going to open up the
books or protect it it doesn't work like
that Legacy is really really difficult
and if you're if you're really committed
to helping the victims uh understand
what has happened then you would support
this bill
and sort of encourage the transparency
that it presents and the North Island
secretary's done a great job in bringing
communities with him and all that
obviously I totally accept that everyone
is against this and I unders in Northern
Ireland and I respect that you know that
that is their job and they represent
particular parts of the population I
don't think it's the wrong thing to do
second if that's because it offers an
amnesty yeah but there is no way it
doesn't offer an amnesty right but first
up it's not an amnesty people who thinks
it's an honestly you don't know what an
amnesty is secondarily you know that you
cannot have laws that disaggregate
between claimants between those you
serve in the military and those
um who didn't so look we have to operate
in the real world we have to operate
with the world as we see it is it is it
where we you know a solution that uh you
know we can all we all want to see well
look I don't think you're going to get
that in in Legacy I think some of these
crimes the evidence just doesn't exist
anymore and we have a duty to make sure
that uh existing structures are not
abused and um
um you know by one side or the other and
that we try and deliver uh fairness for
uh victims in this space at the same
time not allowed the abuse of our
veterans talk to me about shamima begum
should she be allowed to return to the
UK look I think there's a lot of
information in the space with with her
that has not been made public
um you know the slightly Jared when he
was home secretary he made he made his
decision around that and uh I support
him in that I think that case is going
uh through the courts today let's see
what they say but look it's in in spaces
like this with National Security there's
so much information that is not in the
public domain and you have to trust the
processes and Trust the uh the Secretary
of State like Sajid when he made that
decision and the courts to make sure
that we come to the right conclusion I'm
sure she'll be treated fairly she's only
15 when all this happened she was a kid
she was groomed
you know that's something the court will
take into consideration that's you know
it's not for me now can we not um put
her on trial I mean is it not a place
where we can put again but they are they
are working through all these all these
questions in the court and um
look I don't have a view because I I'm
not I'm not uh I'm not um I'm sure you
decided on all the uh high side
intelligence around her
um you know clearly if she's a threat to
this country then um you know we have a
job to keep people safe and uh that's
what the government's determined to do
and we'll do what's your view on uh
nurses being a special case when it
comes to pay uh rewards look I think uh
I think the strikes are really
unfortunate there's a lot of people in
Plymouth who who work in the public
sector I will always argue for them to
get paid more but you know you're
chasing a really difficult problem here
the biggest challenge is inflation and
that's driving up prices across uh
Plymouth and across the country and you
know people like the governor of the
bank of England himself have said that
you know if you continue to chase that
with pay Rises you're never going to end
it so I don't think this is a binary
issue that that you can you know say
well the right to do is I think these
negotiations need to continue people are
negotiating in good faith we'll get to
the end of it look I think uh you could
you can argue as a special case for for
lots of different professions like that
Junior doctors and so on I think uh you
know I think these negotiations need to
be conducted in good faith and I think
we need to bring these strikes to an end
because there's enormous pressure on
Health Services people in my
constituency want to see their health
services working properly and these
strikes and withdrawing of Labor only
makes that more difficult okay just
before I let you go we both know that
you're the king of reality TV
um do you fancy following in Matt
Hancock's footsteps no
thanks for joining us cheers